hi
welcome to another episode of cold
fusion where i cover anything in science
technology business or history
imagine the following movie plot points
in your head
a man who fathered 47 children had an
excessive use of illicit substances
murder and the holding of secrets
involving the deep state sounds like the
details of a hollywood script but you
might not know that these details are
attributed to john mcafee the founder of
mcavee antivirus
his death to this day is shrouded in
mystery but before we get ahead of
ourselves just who was john mcafee and
why do social media audiences not accept
what has been published about his death
this is the story of the rise and demise
of john mcafee let's take a look
[Music]
john mcafee was born on the 18th of
september 1945 in england
he pioneered the anti-virus software
known as mcafee which guards your
computer and data against major cyber
threats including viruses ransomware
malware unwanted programs spyware and
more
before this though mcafee's early life
was riddled with complications his
father was an alcoholic who committed
suicide when jon was just 15 an event
that haunted him till his final days
jon seemingly following in his father's
footsteps gained a bit of a habit for
drinking while he attended college
he was an ambitious entrepreneur early
on in his life amassing a small fortune
by selling magazines door to door
his interest in computing was gained
through the experience of working on
coded punch card systems in the 1960s
this experience aided mcafee in securing
a job at the missouri pacific railroad
in which he helped organize train
schedules
john's madness would show up early here
while at his job he would start
experimenting with harder drugs choosing
lsd john would apparently go to work
many days while high on the substance
he would also buy a bag of the
psychedelic drug known as dmt apparently
he did a one-line sample of the drug and
felt nothing and then proceeded to do
the entire bag
completely hallucinating he ran outside
his workplace and hid behind a waste bin
[Music]
despite the chaos mcafee's career took
him to lockheed martin in the 1980s a
company that specialized in aerospace
and defense
at the time computers were still
relatively new and it would take a
further six years in 1986 for the first
virus to hit computers
john became curious and read up as much
as he could on pc viruses he decided to
create a company mcafee associates to
fight back against a relatively unknown
problem at the time
i was living with my brother-in-law in
santa clara california and he was
reading the local newspaper about this
thing called
brand new thing computer virus
what is this thing i mean a virus that
could replicate itself live move from
one machine to another well that's
fascinating
um so i sat and i thought about it how
on earth could someone do this and then
it occurred to me how
they did it and at the same time it
occurred to me how i could stop it so i
wrote a little program and
two weeks later five million people were
using it interestingly it was one of the
first pieces of computer software to be
distributed across the internet
by the end of the 1980s his organization
was already making five million dollars
per year and some of the biggest
companies in the world were using his
anti-virus platform
it would not be until 1992 that the
sheer functionality of the software
would be tested against the michelangelo
virus infecting 5 million computers
prior to this antivirus for computers
wasn't seen as a must-have product
however michelangelo changed that
enabling mcafee associates to grow as a
company even further
john would resign from mcafee associates
in 1994 but he was just getting started
two years after this he sold his shares
in the company for about a hundred
million dollars for now he would keep a
low profile but later on in his life he
would be no stranger to the limelight
but more on this later
after conquering the world of anti-virus
jon decided to start a new venture a
venture into social media before social
media was even a thing
it's a little known fact but mcafee
would work on a social network project
mcafee's social media site was to be
called tribal voice and at one point it
had over seven hundred thousand members
it also featured an instant messenger
function called powwow it allowed users
to have a virtual whiteboard play sound
files to each other share files
instantaneously with other users with a
simple drag and drop interface it even
allowed users to share their web surfing
experiences concurrently with others
and all of this was in 1994 a full
decade before myspace would rise to
prominence
unfortunately the project never caught
on to go mainstream perhaps it was too
early
the global financial crisis of 2008
affected john's fortune considerably
apparently his 100 million dollars had
shrunk to as little as four million
dollars
however this would not be the final
chapter in his life story and his
dwindling funds did not deter him from
getting the most out of a search for a
wild life
in the late 2000s mcafee began selling
his land and moved to belize a caribbean
country situated on the northeastern
coast of central america
his lifestyle in belize was certainly
not for everyone it defied conventional
living soon enough pictures of him
started surfacing on the internet with a
haram of women and he often had locals
who he used as personal bodyguards armed
with guns
these shady dealings led to rumors about
him making drugs
there were many insane activities that
john got up to in this time including
excessive drug use and allegedly
fathering 47 children
it was through this bizarre lifestyle
that he managed to retain cultural
significance
though at this stage john's mental
health will start to decline rapidly and
he became increasingly paranoid
during this time in belize mcafee
personally felt that he was losing any
form of connection with society
this hiatus away from american tech
culture saw john get involved in the
world of antibiotics the microbiologist
alison adonizo gave him assistance
towards creating a product using plans
to combat illness
though later on alison would accuse john
mcafee of sexual assault
[Music]
as time progressed john's life would get
even more insane
while in belize john was having
disagreements with his neighbor gregory
fowle the disagreements were over his
dogs
according to the documentary gringo the
dangerous life of john mcafee
foul poisoned mcafee's dogs
although mcafee refutes what was said in
the documentary apparently he had given
five thousand dollars to a local hitman
to torture and kill gregory in 2012.
i barely knew gregory fought i'd never
had dinner with him i'd never spoken the
entire five years i was there i said
maybe 50 words to him
he did not like my dogs and the the past
two occasions i had seen him walking the
beach he he complained but so did
everybody how do you feel knowing that
there's going to be people out there who
are going to always suspect that you did
it that's a public perception that that
i have no control over right now i had
no connection whatsoever with mr fall's
death
if someone wants to think otherwise
that's okay
at the time of his passing the family
members of gregory passed mcafee's name
to the authorities
not long after this occurred john mcafee
was mentioned as a person of interest to
the belize government
in 2012 the media outlet vice was
interviewing mcafee in guatemala after
he had snuck out from belize pictures of
him were published usually not a big
deal but these particular pictures
included gps coordinates
this was enough detail for the
guatemalan police to use in order to
hunt down mcafee he was arrested on
charges of illegal entry into the
country
while under arrest some speculate that
john faked a series of heart attacks
real or not he was sent back to america
in 2013 mcafee posted a youtube video
called how to uninstall mcafee software
the footage is comical in nature mcafee
is acting absurd with a bunch of women
surrounding him there's guns chain
smoking and him snorting drugs all while
talking directly to the viewer the video
has 11 million hits on youtube
in 2015 mcafee was arrested in tennessee
for driving under the influence and
being in possession of a firearm while
intoxicated
mcafee would continue being a public
figure and would constantly talk about
cyber security privacy and freedom all
the while the us government was chasing
to recover millions of dollars that they
said that mcafee owed in taxes
john refused to give the government tax
returns between 2014 to 2018 it was his
belief that taxation was theft
interestingly john mcafee would run for
u.s president both for the 2016 and 2020
elections
why do you want to run for president
because sir
the greatest problem facing america
today is cyber war it is on the horizon
larry already two teenagers took out the
entire country of ukraine's power for
one day using a 25 year old piece of
software with 17 lines of code can you
imagine sir what the chinese can do to
us and you tell me who is running today
who can fix this problem
by now mcafee had been avoiding u.s law
enforcement for some years and some of
that time aboard his mega yacht and then
things began to get really strange as if
they weren't already
a tweet by him in 2019 made the claim
that quote the us government would kill
him and cover it up as a suicide and
another tweet would read quote getting
subtle messages from the u.s officials
saying in effect we're coming for you
mcafee we're going to kill yourself end
quote
john had even got a tattoo which read
whacked which was a reference to his
cryptocurrency and also his firm belief
that jeffrey epstein didn't kill himself
on october 3rd 2020 john was in a
spanish airport he was about to board a
flight to istanbul but he was detained
by authority he was sent to prison and
was due to be extradited back to the us
he would be found dead on june 23 2021
in spanish prison he was 75 years old
[Music]
mcafee's death in a spanish prison cell
was shrouded in mystery it proved to be
a fertile ground for online conspiracy
theories and that's not unexpected
considering his social media posts
janus john's widow reportedly told media
outlets that his last words were
i love you and i will call you in the
evening
i blame the u.s authorities for this
tragedy
because of these politically motivated
charges against him my husband is now
dead
he did not deserve to die in a filthy
prison
like a caged animal the associated press
though did report that he was found with
a suicide note on him
allegedly john had tried to kill himself
before in february in a different part
of the barcelona jail
a psychiatrist made the assessment that
john was just attention-seeking and it
was a stunt but it resulted in him being
moved to another part of the facility
the main reason that people doubt that
john mcafee killed himself was that he
claimed to have a dead man switch and
this would release a number of sensitive
documents
in 2019 mcafee was recorded stating
quote i've collected files on corruption
in governments for the first time i'm
naming names and specifics i'll begin
with a corrupt cia agent and two
bahamian officials coming today if i'm
arrested or disappear 31 plus terabytes
of incriminating data will be released
to the press
even more controversy stands surrounding
john's death when his instagram posted a
mysterious q
some say that q is a reference to q
others speculate that it could be a key
to the code of the dead man switch
a day after his death a twitter user who
had engaged with mcafee released a
website which was titled contingency
plan activated something big is coming
the website is linked to mcafee's
cryptocurrency whacked and has a timer
countdown which ended on the 27th of
july
to date no bombshell information has
been released
some say it was all just a big scam
suicide or not the death of john mcafee
marks the end of one of the most
eccentric tech moguls in history his
legacy and the story surrounding him
will be spoken about for many years to
come
from being a pioneer in distributing
software over the internet and creating
one of the first social media sites in
history to being a wanted man for murder
and tax evasion john's life was
certainly a wild ride
his story is interesting because he was
clearly intelligent and a visionary in
select areas but his character in
history was so wild that you couldn't
trust much of what he said so the
question still remains was mcafee simply
a crazed and troubled man who gave up in
prison or did another party take him out
nobody can know for sure but the comment
section in this one will be very
interesting so thanks for watching my
name is degogo and you've been watching
cold fusion and i'll see you again soon
for the next video
cheers guys
have a good one
[Music]
foreign
you